[Música]
momento de nuestra revista de prensa con
Rosa Pérez más de hoy como es costumbre
Rosa temas que definitivamente
deberíamos leer largamente Buen día para
usted Buen día Ángela El Salto publica
una entrevista en exclusiva hecha por el
periodista Julio zamarrón a Pedro
castillo y está titulada me presentan
como un monstruo soy el presidente del
Perú es la primera entrevista de
Castillo desde que fue detenido
efectivamente Y es una entrevista que
tal y como vemos en este texto fue
realizada de forma oral y manuscrita
porque estaban prohibidos el ingreso de
cualquier aparato de grabación dentro
del penitenciario de hecho en la prensa
peruana se discute las implicaciones que
pueda tener esta entrevista ya que no
estaba aprobada por las autoridades
penitenciarias penitenciarias tanto para
Pedro Castillo como para los
funcionarios de barbadillo en la penal
de máxima seguridad donde se encuentra
castillo y donde nos recuerda este texto
también se encuentra Alberto fujimori
recordemos bien empieza este texto con
una la descripción para ponernos en
situación de las condiciones de
encarcelamiento de Castillo dice la
celda carece de ventanas y de luz
natural aunque se le permite el acceso a
un pequeño huerto donde está cultivando
patatas y maíz en el interior de la
celda hay un pequeño hornillo para
cocinar y un escritorio con algún libro
en este momento el presidente se
encuentra leyendo el arte de la guerra
de
la primera pregunta que hace el
periodista es si teme por su vida Pedro
Castillo a lo que él responde claramente
que sí por su vida y la de su familia
Pero aclara no solo desde ahora temo por
mi vida desde la segunda vuelta de la
campaña para ser presidente y en
relación a su familia dice que su madre
No sabe que él está preso su padre si lo
sabe pero todavía no lo ha podido
visitar y que de su mujer y de sus hijos
sabe poca cosa más allá de que están
refugiados en México agradece
particularmente a su mujer Lilia la
resistencia a lo largo de este del
mandato de Castillo no dijo que su
esposa muchas veces quiso irse de Lima
con sus hijos porque no aguantaba los
ataques a su vestimenta dice a nuestras
raíces andinas de la forma en la que
hablábamos había discriminación racial y
este mismo racismo más adelante en la
entrevista Pedro Castillo lo achaca como
una causa principal de la situación
actual del Perú dice concretamente el
racismo histórico que prohibido y sigue
viviendo El Perú así como el clasismo y
la desigualdad social y económica es la
razón por la que hoy se vive una masacre
Más allá de las opiniones siempre es
Interesante como se humanizan a los
personajes no y más un personaje tan
relevante como lo es Pedro Castillo
ahora otra de las preguntas clave en
esta historia es que ocurrió el 7 de
diciembre y si se trató de subvertir
realmente la institucionalidad peruana
efectivamente Y es una de las cosas más
interesantes no de leer esta entrevista
de ver como Castillo vivió los hechos no
dice jamás intente subvertir la
institucionalidad peruana yo quería
acercarme al pueblo fue un día de hacer
eco para los nadies de hecho más
adelante señala que el congreso está
deslegitimado en su opinión y que
cambiar la Constitución es el sentir del
pueblo dejar atrás el legado fujimorista
y dice me reafirmo en que necesitamos
una asamblea popular Constituyente
declara admiración para la valentía de
sus compatriotas y sus hermanos
encarcelados asesinados por pedir lo
mismo dice son los héroes del país no
renuncia a este sueño al de una asamblea
popular Constituyente y asegura por eso
hice lo que dice ese mensaje la nación
el 7 de diciembre asegura que fue su
decisión y la de nadie más dice después
del mensaje la nación Aníbal Torres y
los otros ministros estaban muy
confundidos y ahora viene un relato de
cómo vivió esta detención no dice
después del mensaje lo primero que pensé
fue en mi familia fui a dejarlos a la
embajada de México en ningún momento
quería fugarme estábamos en el camino
cuando la policía nos detiene luego
recuerdo momentos en partes dice tengo
un problema en el oído uso un aparato
para poder escuchar no escuchaba las
indicaciones que me decían hubo un
momento en el que sólo escuchaba
silencio
Bueno qué responde Castillo cuando le
preguntan qué opina de quienes
consideran que lo que él hizo fue un
autogolpe dice que al contrario él es
víctima de un complot organizado por la
derecha peruana al servicio de la
derecha internacional dice soy el primer
presidente rural maestro y campesino no
me querían en el gobierno nunca Y fui
elegido por el pueblo nunca me lo
perdonaron y hace referencia a como él
iba en contra de los intereses de la
oligarquía que llama extractivista
neoliberal y capitalista asegura todo el
problema tiene que ver con el litio el
imperialismo quiere el litio y mi
gobierno quería darle el litio al pueblo
bueno Y finalmente habla también en una
parte sobre su relación con Dina
boluarte efectivamente Y dice que él la
conoció porque el Perú libre el partido
la propuso como vicepresidenta dice
luego me di cuenta de la maldad de esta
mujer la califica como calculadora
ambiciosa sumamente racista y clasista
dictadora que trabaja el fujimorismo y
dice es una mujer que irá presa por
violaciones de Derechos Humanos asegura
que Perú vive una dictadura y bajo
situaciones crímenes de terrorismo de
Estado cree sin embargo que la
solidaridad internacional puede revertir
esta situación agradece la solidaridad a
Bolivia Argentina Chile Colombia México
entre otros países en cambio dice que
Estados Unidos y la Unión Europea hacen
fuerza para oprimir a su país entre
otros no dice que lo que le ha ocurrido
es comparable al caso de Cristina
kirchner en Argentina o Lula en Brasil y
por último Angela destacamos Una última
pregunta Y es que el periodista le dice
como expresidente del Perú Qué salida ve
a esta situación actual de estallido
social en su país y él le corrige dice
Considero que sigo siendo el presidente
del Perú como peruano no reconozco a
este gobierno genocida nunca he tocado
un arma en mi vida soy el presidente del
Perú y si me está encarcelando por un
delito de rebelión que no mire en el
contexto que vive en este momento El
Perú está muy bien ver estos artículos y
poder tener la mayor información posible
digamos que es lo más responsable no
efectivamente gracias a usted Rosa
gracias